Thank You Janice for letting me be your
friend it's been an honor thank you
Miley Cyrus in tears paying tribute to
late voice contestant Janice Freeman who
died earlier this month at 33 after
complications from lupus and a bronchial
infection
Miley attended Genesis memorial service
on Monday to help celebrate her life I
just want to clear up a rumor
I was never her coach ever
she was always mine the pair first met
in 2017 during season 13 of The Voice I
better now that you sang it than the
original I pick my feet it's clear Miley
and Genesis friendship was special and
extended for beyond the show I learned
more from her than anyone that I've ever
gotten the honor to be in the room with
not just vocally I should have gotten
more lessons than I did but she taught
me everything joined on stage by her
father Billy Ray Cyrus and a group of
musicians Miley sang a soulful rendition
of Amazing Grace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not the first time my lease paid
tribute to Janice shortly after she died
Miley shared a photo from this
performance together on the voice along
with a lengthy caption that read in part
quote how you were so selfless I'll
never understand the way you found the
good in everything you are now a rainbow
you were the only artist ever that I
tried so hard to sign was going to
create a label just so you could be on
it
[Music]
you guys know
[Music]